Ember is an advanced
framework built by Yehuda Katz and
others who are pushing the boundaries
of the JavaScript language.
So Ember makes use of JavaScript
language features that sometimes haven't
been standardized yet.
When building Ember apps it's important
to know how to use JavaScript promises
which makes it easy to write and
manage asynchronous code.
ES6 modules, some files in an Ember app
are included into other files using
modules and imports.
And ES6 Syntax.
Features like arrow functions,
destructuring, and template strings.
But don't worry,
this isn't too important because we can
write everything using standard ES5.
We have a course on promises, so check
that out if you have any questions.
Links to these topics are in
the instructor notes.